ودعا البيان الختامي للقبه الخليجيه
الصينيه الى تعزيز الشراكه الاستراتيجيه
القائمه بين مجلس التعاون والصين ودفعها
نحو افاق جديده واكد البيان على اهميه
الدعم المتبادل بين الجانبين بما يحقق
المصالح المشتركه حيث تدعم الصين جهود دول
المجلس لصيانه سيادتها والحفاظ على امرها
واستقرارها وعلفه البيان الى مواصله تعميق
التعاون بين الجانبين في مجالات الطاقه
والتجاره والاستثمار والماليه والصناعه
والتكنولوجيا واكد الجانبان على ضروره ان
تقوم العلاقات بين دول الخليج وايران على
اساسه مبدا حسن الجوار وعدم التدخل في
الشؤون الداخليه كما اكد البيان على
المواقف الداعمه لكل الجهود الدوليه
الرمليه الى التهدئه وايجاد حل سياسيا
لانهاء الازمه في اوكرانيا
البيان بنجاحه دوله قطر في استضافه بطوله
كاس العالم وحسني تنظيمها واثارها
الايجابيه في الارث الانساني والتقارب
الحضري والثقافي بين الشعوب